hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast finding pathologic
t-cells in rheumatoid arthritis by mass
cytometry presented by Deepak Rao MD PhD
with the technology introduction by
Michele Poole and PhD we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
fluid I'm Flo dime develops manufactures
and markets life science and litical and
preparatory systems for markets such as
mass cytometry high-throughput genomics
and single-cell genomics we sell to
leading academic institutions clinical
research laboratories and pharmaceutical
biotechnology and agricultural
biotechnology companies worldwide our
systems are based on proprietary micro
fluidics and multi parameter math
cytometry technology and are designed to
significantly simplify experimental
workflow increase throughput and reduce
costs while providing excellent data
quality food on products are provided
for research use only not for use in
diagnostic procedures to learn more
about fluid ein please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
you'll be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right finally if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce our speakers dr. michelle
pullin earned her bachelor's degree from
smith college and her PhD in immunology
from the University of Colorado Denver
after completing a postdoctoral
fellowship at national Jewish Health in
2003 she joined BD Biosciences as an
instructor in the customer education
department in 2012 dr. Pugh enjoined DVF
Sciences as a field applications
scientist and became manager of the
North American field application
scientist team shortly after DVS was
acquired by fluid I'm in 2014 dr. Deepak
Rao is an instructor in medicine and
co-director of the human immunology
Center at Brigham and Women's Hospital
in Boston after completing undergraduate
studies at Harvard University it
contained an MD and a PhD in you know in
you know biology from the Yale
University School of Medicine where he
studied human t-cell responses to
transplanted organs in the laboratory of
dr. Jordan tober he then completed his
internal medicine residency and
Rheumatology fellowship training at
Brigham and Women's Hospital dr. Rao
received the 2014 American College of
Rheumatology Distinguished Fellow award
and the 2016 Rheumatology Research
Foundation mellowest endowment
designation for his research
characterizing lymphocyte abnormalities
in patients with rheumatic diseases his
work employs high dimensional and
functional analyses of t-cells in blood
and tissue samples from patients with
rheumatoid arthritis lupus and other
rheumatic diseases please join me in
welcoming dr. Poulin I will now turn the
presentation over to her thank you Judy
in advance of dr. Rao's presentation I'd
like to give you an introduction to mass
cytometry as you know biology is very
heterogeneous and biological systems
consist of heterogeneous cell types each
with diverse functions and functional
States this complexity demands high
dimensional proteomics panels that can
simultaneously measure both the breadth
and depth of the system with single-cell
resolution mass cytometry enables this
with the ability to look at more than 50
parameters on millions of cells
uniquely enables the discovery of new
biology as well as comprehensive
functional profiling across a broad
range of research areas including basic
research drug discovery and clinical
research to discuss math cytometry in a
bit more detail I'll go through the five
elements of math cytometry first is
metals we utilize metals as tags on our
probes and we currently have more than
50 high purity metal isotope tags
available because of the purity of these
isotopic tags there is minimal
background from signal overlap between
isotopes and because these metals do not
occur naturally in biological systems
there is no background from endogenous
cellular components these metals when
attached to probes can be combined into
panels to do this we have available our
max part antibodies fluid on has a
catalog of more than 600 pre conjugated
antibodies at this time with specificity
to both human and mouse markers these
are against both phenotype phenotypic
and functional markers and can be
purchased individually or as part of
panel kits in addition we offer 35
labeling tips so that you can conjugate
your own antibodies with these metal
tags and fluid I'm also has custom
conjugation services available in
addition to antibody probes we also self
cell ID reagents such as bar coding and
cisplatin as a live dead indicator once
the panel has been designed your cells
are then stained with this panel by
protocols very similar to what you may
currently use for flow cytometry the
stain cells are then introduced into the
Helios mask site ometer where they will
pass through a high-energy plasma which
will ionize each cell the resulting ions
will then be read by a single
Tector and all of these ions can be
separated with a resolution of one
dalton the helium a site ometer has a
mass range from 75 to 209 Dalton's
allowing the measurement of 135 channels
this allows for measurement of all of
our existing tags and any reagents that
we develop in the future this means that
they can be added to your current panel
without any upgrade to the instrument
Hardware finally the Helios collects
multi parametric data for large numbers
of cells per sample enabling proteomic
profiling for breadth of cell types all
in a single tube to finish off I'd just
like to show you the math cytometry
publication ramp as you'll see over the
last several years there's been a huge
increase in peer-reviewed publications
utilizing math cytometry technology
showing that is Nabal INRIA cross a
range of research fields around the
world thank you and I'll pass this back
to Judy thank you dr pawan for your
presentation we will now hear from dr.
Rao
Judy it's my pleasure today to talk with
you about our work using math cytometry
to find pathologic t-cells in rheumatoid
arthritis
I have no disclosures I've structured
the talk today in three parts in the
first part I'll describe our overall
approach to using site off to study
inflamed tissues and blood and
autoimmune diseases in the second part
I'll tell you a story about a particular
example that we've published recently
identifying a unique population of
t-cells in rheumatoid arthritis samples
and then lastly I'll mention the use of
site off in a consortium the
accelerating medicines partnership that
studies rheumatoid arthritis and lupus
so in human translational studies in
particular those that are focused on
diseases it's often important to obtain
samples from patients affected with that
condition that can be tissue samples
that can be blood samples and in our
studies we tend to use both whenever we
can we emphasize getting tissue samples
because they're tremendously useful the
examples in the autoimmune diseases are
for example synovium and rheumatoid
arthritis kidney biopsies and lupus
nephritis skin and psoriasis the guts
and inflammatory bowel disease the
challenge here is that these tissues are
difficult to obtain oftentimes and
typically they're quite small so you may
only end up with a few thousand tens of
thousands of cells the sample
preparation is challenging because it
typically involves digesting the tissue
to generate a single self suspension but
the deficit is that one is able to
directly a say the active immune
response because of the challenges in
dealing with tissue we oftentimes rely
on analyses of peripheral blood as well
and because of these difficulties we
think that it's likely that peripheral
blood will remain the primary source for
analyzing immune cells in clinical
practice of course blood easily it's
easily obtained it provides a lot of
cells from
50 milliliters blood one can obtain 10
to 50 million peripheral blood
mononuclear cells the blood can be
sampled longitudinally and repeatedly
over time and there is the possibility
to capture activated immune cells that
are in transit in the circulation in
particular if you know what you're
looking for our general approach employs
a two complementary strategies and for
one we use site offs to generate
detailed cellular phenotypes in a sample
and in parallel and often in sequence
we'll use traditional flow cytometry
distort cells of interest so for example
with site off one can analyze the sample
in substantial detail to characterize
populations we'll use this to identify
subpopulations of immune cells that are
expanded or depleted in patient samples
relative to controls once we've
identified populations that are vigorous
then we'll focus on those and sort them
by flow cytometry for additional studies
either RNA sequencing analyses by low
input RNA seek transcript
transcriptomics single-cell
transcriptomics and functional analyses
so let me tell you that about how we've
used the strategy in the disease of
rheumatoid arthritis so by way
backgrounds rheumatoid arthritis is a
prototypical autoimmune disease directed
against the joints it's common in that
it affects up to 1% of the population
and what you see in the slide here is an
example on the left of what normal
synovium looks like here we're looking
inside an e-bike arthroscopy and as
though it's difficult to appreciate that
there is a thin synovial lining that
covers the joint it rooms what arthritis
this thin lining is the target of the
inflammatory response and it becomes
hyperplastic it becomes hyper vascular
infiltrated with immune cells and that
synovium then starts to expand in and
vade into the surrounding structures
we're really shouldn't be so it degrades
the cartilage it begins to degrade the
bone and this causes ultimately
destruction of the joint we can schema
ties the inflammatory response in the
joint here with this cartoon that
highlights three aspects of the
inflammatory process so in the bottom
left you can see the detection of an
accumulation of T cells and B cells
this is a typical finding in rheumatoid
arthritis and those T cells and B cells
produce factors that then activate and
recruit additional innate immune cells
like macrophages mast cells the
inflammatory response then initiates a
reaction from the synovial fibroblast
reline the joint those fibroblasts
become activated they begin to
proliferate and is detected on the right
you can see illustrated the idea that
those synovial fibroblasts invade into
the cartilage they interact with
osteoclasts that then stimulate
destruction of the bone so we've been
interested to try and assay the various
cell populations that participate in
this inflammatory response broadly so
one of the methods we use to do that is
mass spectometry your sites off so our
typical workflow is to obtain synovial
tissues that's the joint tissue either
at the time of arthroplasty when the
patient undergoes the joint replacements
and that tissue becomes available or
through research protocol synovial
biopsies in either case we digest the
tissues that generate a single self
suspension and here we've analyzed
samples with a Mac cytometry panel the
panel is shown on the right and you can
see that it includes markers to identify
stromal cells like fibroblasts with
markers like proto plannin cat hair and
11s ap identifies endothelial cells
markers like ze cat hair and then it
includes a large number of markers to
identify
look at sight populations and
subpopulations therein so on the left
side of this of this slide what you see
is a vis need visualization of mass
spectometry data from the synovial
tissue sample here in this type of
visualization each dot is a cell and the
cells are arranged in this
two-dimensional plot based on how
similar they are to one another in a
multi-dimensional way and the upshot is
that cells that are similar to one
another end up clustered together in an
island of sorts in these plots the color
represents the level of expression of
the marker that's labeled at the top so
here in the top left hand panel
represents the expression is gd3 and you
can see that there are two T
subpopulations identified by cd3 one of
those populations also expresses cd4
here so those are the cd4 T cells and in
contrast is another population here that
expresses cd8 this is the cd8 positive T
cells you can also make out fibroblasts
which Express protoplanet down here on
the bottom left and monocytes and
macrophages from the top right
identified by the expression of cd14 so
you can appreciate that with this one
visualization of the site off data you
can recognize multiple populations of
cells but leukocytes and stromal cells
you also can get a sense that within
some of these populations there's
heterogeneity so for example in the cd4
is there are at least two populations
that are easily identified and others
within there as well we can look at the
same type of data by traditional biaxial
gating here again looking at NASA
commentary data from a synovial tissue
sample now rather than using a multi
dimensional visualization tool we're
just looking at a bio field plots of
particular markers of interest so again
we can resolve fibroblasts and
leukocytes based on the expression of
proto planet and cd45 in the top left if
we follow
follow the leukocytes we can again see
monocytes are macrophages identified by
cd14 t-cells by CD 3 and on the right we
can see the CD 3 positive t-cells
divided into cd4 and cd8 just as you'd
expect and results quite nicely and of
course we can go further and identify
the heterogeneity within these
populations so for the fibroblasts we
can see that there are different
populations that might be identified
based on here the expression of CD 90
and cd34 amongst the monocytes for
macrophages we can clearly see a
distinct population that expresses a
high level of CCR to among this
population which are neither t-cells nor
monocytes as expected we see many cells
that Express cd19 so those are the
b-cells and a heterogeneity amongst the
D cells including a population with
bright expression of cd38
which may suggest that these are plasma
cells the plasma blasts in the
population and of course amongst the cd4
cells we can resolve subpopulations as
well here showing for example a
population with bright expression of
pd-1 also expressing CC r2 and so in the
next few minutes we'll will focus on is
the heterogeneity within the cd4 t-cell
population so let me tell you first for
a minute why I focus on the cd4 cells in
rheumatoid arthritis so a couple of
points about this
so first the genetics and rheumatoid
arthritis strongly point toward cd4
cells as important players that is that
the strongest risk alleles for
rheumatoid arthritis encode MHC class 2
molecules the primary purpose of which
are to present antigen to cd4 T cell we
know that rheumatoid arthritis synovium
as I told you is often heavily
infiltrated with cd4 T cells and we know
clinically that blocking t-cell
activation with a medication that bad
assets which is ctla4 IG effectively
treats rheumatoid arthritis in many
patients so the case for an important
role for cd4 is is quite strong
however the key pathologic affective
functions of cd4 cells and rheumatoid
arthritis have remained it generally
unclear so we've been interested to
explore the potential functions of
different T cell populations that
infiltrate the joints in rheumatoid
arthritis one way we've approached this
is using mass cytometry
now to try and identify subpopulations
of T cells within these samples with the
hope of identifying populations that are
particularly important in driving
pathology so what's shown on this slide
is again Mac cytometry data of a sample
obtained from a patient with rheumatoid
arthritis joint sample and here what
we've done is we focused only on the cd4
T cells so this is gated on cd4 positive
C D 3 positive T cells and we've
stripped away all the other cells and
then we focused the visit analysis on
this population so again each dot is the
cell the cells are arranged in a on the
two-dimensional plot based on how
similar they are to one another in a
multi-dimensional way and the color
represents the level of expression of
the marker at the top so you can see
what I what I've laid out here is the
expression of five different markers
that are sometimes considered activation
markers on T cells or markers that
should suggest that the T cell has been
activated in the recent past and for one
you can appreciate that the expression
patterns are different for these
different markers so for example C D 69
is fairly broadly expressed by the T
cells in the joint
whereas cd38 it shows a much more
restricted pattern what stood out to us
here is this large population of T cells
with quite bright expression of PD one
you can see that some of those cells
co-expressed MHC class 2 some of them Co
Express I cause so we're interested in
trying to understand this population
better if we use traditional biaxial
gating you can identify the same
population so here it's the same same
sample the same data is now just shown
in by axial gates
and if we gate on the cd4 T cells you
can see a population with very bright
expression of pd-1 often times Co
expressing MHC class 2 often times Co
expressing I cos and this is quantified
on the right and six different donors
and we've used a couple of complementary
strategies to try and validate these
results and and demonstrate them in
different ways so here shown on this
slide is now flow cytometry analysis not
of synovial tissue but at synovial fluid
so this is joint fluid to inflamed fluid
that comes out of the joints of patients
with rheumatoid arthritis it may be
obtained by a clinician who's treating
the patient and quite satisfyingly we
could similarly see a population of
t-cells with very bright PD one
expression here by flow cytometry or
synovial fluid and you can appreciate
that this population almost almost that
displays a distinct pattern by flow
cytometry and with a distinct level of
expression compared to the rest of the
so interestingly these cells were
identified as expanded in patients with
zero positive rheumatoid arthritis which
means rheumatoid arthritis when the
patients have an auto antibody either a
rheumatoid factor antibody or an anti
CCP antibody and really not expanded in
patients that have inflammatory
arthritis that's not associated with an
auto antibody and that could be 0
negative rheumatoid arthritis psoriatic
arthritis juvenile arthritis so the
distinction here at a site or metric
level between 0 positive RA and 0
negative r3 disease is really quite
striking and I'm not sure there's
another marker that makes this
distinction as well
as another complementary approach we use
indigo fluorescence microscopy to see if
we could detect the same types of cells
within the tissue and learn something
about their localization so here what's
shown is confocal microscopy of a
synovial biopsy sample on the bottom on
the Left panel you can see most of the
panel is taken up by the tissue itself
and you can see there's aggregates of
immune cells so the b-cells are in green
t-cells are in red and the p1 expressing
t-cells are in blue so in the merge one
can see that there are a number of
purple cells which are which are PD one
positive t-cells and oftentimes they are
closely approximated to be cells in the
sample
so now by three different approaches
we've been able to identify a population
of T cells with bright PD one expression
within the synovium so we then spent
quite amount quite a fair amount of time
trying to understand what are these
cells what might they do and we
considered a few possibilities so one
possibility is that these are generally
activated T cells another possibility is
that they're exhausted or dysfunctional
T cells and a third possibility that we
considered is that these are follicular
helper T cells a specific subset of cd4
cells let me just say a word about
follicular helper cells so follicular
helper cells are typically identified as
CX c r v positive pd-1 positive cells
they're well known to promote b-cell
recruitment and maturation in follicles
and lymph nodes they produce typically
il 21 and 6 CL 13 which is the ligands
for CXC r 5 and then characteristically
Express a high level of a transcription
factor PCL 6 so we're interested to ask
are the PD one high cells and synovial
tissue are these follicular helper cells
we did this by looking for CX c r v and
the answer here is really know that
while while you can see cells with quite
high PD one expression in synovial fluid
or synovial tissue here shown at the top
on the left
most of these cells do not express the
xgr 5 and this is in contrast to send up
to compo as a positive control on the
right we quantified this in nine
different synovial fluid donors and ten
different synovial tissue samples and
the observation is really that the vast
majority of the PD 1hi cells and
synovium do not express CXC or five and
so we wouldn't consider them follicular
helper T so we then try to ask further
about the potential function of these
cells in the way that we did this was to
sort PD one high and PD one negative
populations out of synovial fluid
samples from rheumatoid arthritis
patients so what's shown here is rt-pcr
of sorted sub populations of cells and
the cells are sorted based on whether
they express PD one or not and then
again subdivided based on whether they
Co expressed MHC class 2 or not the
interesting thing about this was that
while the PD one high cells did not
express heil with higher levels of il-2
they expressed much higher levels of il
21 and 60 o 13 relative to PD one
negative T cells so here the il 21 is
about a hundred fold increased CX 0 13 a
thousandfold increase and the expression
of these two molecules suggested a
potential role as B cell helpers in that
these are factors that are typically
associated with follicular helper T
cells we confirm this by intracellular
cytokine standing here sorting again PD
one negative cells PD one high cells and
this time PD one intermediate cells as
well sort them keep them in vitro
stimulate them and then analyze cytokine
expression by intracellular cytokines
painting and the observation is the same
that the PD one high cells on the right
in each plot they don't express much
il-2 but they express more frequently
Express I'll 21 and much more frequently
expressed exhale 13 given the production
of these two molecules we suspected that
that PD one high cells out of the
synovium may be able to interact with
b-cells and promote detailed responses
and in fact that's the case so
we sorted pd-1 high cells or pd-1
negative cells out of synovial tissue
out of synovial fluid and also out of
blood co-cultures them with memory
b-cells
stimulated these cultures in vitro for a
week and asked about the ability of the
t-cells to drive B cell differentiation
into plasma cells
the observation is that from all three
sites these PD one high cells are most
able to induce B cell differentiation
into plasma cell so what I'm telling
told you so far is that by math
cytometry right we identified that zero
positive rheumatoid arthritis synovium
is infiltrated by a large population of
pd-1 highest exc are five negative cd4
cells and this B cells express al 21 and
see XEL 13 and they promote plasma cell
differentiation in vitro so we were then
interested to ask well how does he sell
differ from t follicular helper cells we
did it by a couple of approaches so one
approach was to look at the expression
of some of the key transcription factors
here is done by intracellular cytokine
intracellular flow cytometry on the left
is looking at the expression of bcl6
versus blimp one and on the right is
looking at the expression of mass these
are isolated in both synovial fluid
cells and synovial tissue cells and the
cells are divided based on the
expression of PD 1 and 60 r5 and what
you can appreciate is that as expected
the PD one hi six certified positive
cells from synovial fluid there's from
synovial tissue in this case these are
the follicular helper cells they
expressed a very high ratio of bcl6
Bloom point this is what would be
predicted but in contrast the p1 highest
exe r5 negative cells the cells I've
been telling you about these cells do
not express an elevated ratio of BC of
62.1 and in fact they express a somewhat
higher level of blimp ones than the rest
of the cells so indicating a difference
in the expression of the two key
transcription factors in this population
at the same time when we looked at mass
expression both pd1 high CXC are five
negative cells and pd1 high CXC are five
positive cells show an elevated level of
expression of math which is relevant
because this is a transcription factor
that's known to drive expression of IL
21 so both shared and distinct features
looking at the level of transcription
factor expression we approach this
question more broadly again turning to
math let Thomas read so here we've
analyzed cells cd4 T cells from
peripheral blood samples and study them
with a back cytometry panel that
includes 34 markers including many
markers to help subset populations of
cd4 cells again what's shown is a
visionary visualization of the data and
what stood out from these analyses is
that the cells with high PD 1 expression
tended to cluster together in this type
of analysis and that some of them would
co-expressed extr 5 while others
wouldn't but the same time that the PD 1
high cells width and without 6005 tended
to end up in the same area and so what
I'm talking about is this spot here
where within this pink circle you can
appreciate that there are some 6005
positive cells that are sitting right
adjacent to many cells that do not
express txt or 5 and they're unified by
high expression of pd 1 so it suggests
that these cells when you consider a
sort of multi-dimensional phenotype are
quite similar and across the panel and
again we can we can identify some
heterogeneity within these populations
we're then able to ask about the
differences or similarities in the level
of expression of many other markers that
are included in the mass spectrometry
panel so when we compared PG 1 high CX 0
5 negative cells to pd 1 highest extr 5
positive so there is a similarly
increased expression of a couple of
markers for example
I cost at the same time there are a
couple of proteins that stands out it's
quite different
so ccr7 expression is lower in the CXC
are five negative cells than the CHCO
five positive cell and on the other hand
t-bet is higher in the CXC are five
negative cells compared to the six here
five positive one so we use my cytometry
here to assess broadly a number of
markers of particular interest to try
and identify differences and
similarities between these two
populations to complement this analysis
we took an even broader approach which
is to use low input RNA sequencing so
here we've sorted eight different
populations of memory cd4 T cells
subdivided based on their expression or
lack of expression of PD 160 r5i cost
and MHC class 2 you can see how they've
been divided at the bottom we sorted
these cells from research eight
different populations from four
different rheumatoid arthritis patients
and what's shown here is a principal
component analysis to look at the global
relationship of these cell populations
and the observation that comes out is
that the cells with high PD one
expression without CXC are five ten the
cluster together these are represented
in the fire colors at the bottom and
they're robustly separated from the PD
one highest ext or five negative cells
the safe terrified positive cells which
are at the top and these are the cells
in green that we would consider it
I think unambiguously follicular helper
T cells the the difference between these
two populations or their separation in
the plot suggests that there are major
global transcriptomic differences that
go beyond just the expression of 6:05
yes or no so here using three different
approaches one specifically acting
transcription factors to using vas
cytometry to analyze proteins of
interest in three using a broad
transcriptomic approach we can identify
those shared features and distinct
features between these two populations
when we asked about differentially
expressed genes between PD one highest
extr five- cells and PB one high 6005
positive cells interestingly one set of
genes stood out to us our set of
chemokine receptors so the CXC our five
negative cells have a much higher
expression of CCR - for example than the
follicular helped result and it sort of
makes sense so follicular helper cells
expressed extr 5 and the CXC are 5
negative cells Express a different
cohort of chemokine receptors and in
this case there are a set of chemokine
receptors that are associated with
migration to inflamed tissues we
confirmed the sub servation for a few of
these proteins around here I think most
strikingly for CCR - so what's shown
here is again flow cytometry data
looking at T cells that have come out of
a rheumatoid arthritis tissue sample and
as I've shown you before could see a
large population of T cells with high PD
one expression without CXC are five just
shown on the left and when we look at
those same cells and ask about the
expression of CCR - you can appreciate
that there's about half of them that
Express CCR - so this is interesting
because it's a population of cells that
expresses not only do they lack 6005
they express a different chemokine
receptor but as we've shown in vitro
they are functional at helping B cell
maturation and differentiation I alluded
to this in the past couple slides but
we're also this is to show explicitly
that we're also able to find these pg1
high 60 or five negative cells in the
blood and here on the left you can see a
visited visualization of cells from
synovial fluid sample of blood sample
from the same patient and there are in
the blood cells with high PD one
expression with a similar
multi-dimensional phenotype they're just
much rarer in the blood than in the
fluid or tissue so if you know what
you're looking for you can find them but
it's difficult to detect them sort of
broadly otherwise and indeed
in the blood if you quantify the
frequency of these cells they are
increased specifically in the patients
would serve positive rheumatoid
arthritis shown on the right and and not
really in patients obscure a negative
arthritis or spondyloarthropathies
that's the SP a so consistent with the
synovial fluid finding the population
that's specifically enriched in ceará
positive RA
we remain interested in trying to
understand one of the features in
seropositive rheumatoid arthritis
patients that may be associated with an
expanded frequency of these cells and
this is showing some of our initial
analyses to get at this question so in
the left you can see that the rheumatoid
arthritis patients have been divided
based on having low disease activity or
higher disease activity and those
patients with the highest frequency tend
to have high disease activity shown here
and separately in a different cohort of
patients where we were able to get blood
samples longitudinally here before
starting a new treatment and after
starting a new treatment we saw a
reduction in the frequency of the PG one
highest extr five- cells in patients who
were successfully treated with a new
therapy so it suggests that the
frequency of these cells is higher in
patients with active disease and that it
can come down with successful treatment
so let me summarize what I've shown you
here to say that starting with mass
spectometry we identified a markedly
expanded population of pd-1 high 60 are
five negative cells in rheumatoid
arthritis that these cells Express
aisle 21 and 6-0 13 and show the ability
to help b-cells and yet they have a
distinct transcriptional and proteomic
signature from follicular helper cells
characterised in particular by a unique
migratory capacity suggested by the
expression of different chemokines
centers
I've also shown you that by
immunofluorescence microscopy we can see
these cells into tissues oftentimes
adjacent to B cells and then looking at
the circulation we find these cells
expanded in the blood of patients with
active rheumatoid arthritis and that the
frequency decreases for therapy so I'd
like to just take a minute s or put
these findings in the context of what's
been described so we're familiar with
the idea of a follicular helper t-cell
that expresses CXC are 5s and it follows
the the ligand safe Co 13 into lymph
node follicles and they're in a lymph
node follicle it interacts with b-cells
by producing factors like al 21 and 6 al
13 to help drive a germinal Center
reaction and what we would suggest is
that there's a distinct population of T
cells
similarly identified by high PD one
expression but in this in this case
expressing a different set of chemokine
receptors ones that take cells not the
lymphoid follicles but two enflamed
peripheral sites here for example the
joint within the joint these cells which
we were calling peripheral helper
t-cells may interact with b-cells
similarly producing the same factors but
in fact drives a local antibody
production local b-cell response which
is different from the process that goes
on in in lymph nodes so we've suggested
just as there are follicular helper
t-cells that go to follicles we
suggested that we might consider these
cells peripheral helper t-cells that go
to peripheral tissues in the last minute
or two let me just comment on then the
use of these kinds of strategies more
broadly in a in a multi-site consortium
so we participate in a consortium called
the accelerating medicines partnership
in RA and SLE the emphasis is to work on
rheumatoid arthritis and lupus and the
network is really spurred by an NIH
industry partnership to use high
dimensional analysis to study patient
samples in detail the the network is
employing site soft it's also employing
RNA sequencing using single cell and low
input methodologies and the emphasis
really to study a tissue and in parallel
to study blood to look for key
pathologic pathways and potential new
biomarkers in rheumatoid arthritis have
been showing you here the emphasis is to
look at synovial tissue and then move
this anthesis to look at the kidney and
also some extent looking at the skin
sigh cough has a substantial role in the
network and that for both rheumatoid
arthritis patients and lupus patients as
well as controls that are recruited
there's a large type of analysis that's
planned for blood samples using both
peripheral blood mononuclear cells as
well as total leukocytes which is meant
to imply reject which actually is a
peripheral blood where the red cells
have been lifes but the granulocytes
remain intact so it allows one to
analyze both monitor clear cells and
granulocytes we're using multiple panels
to do this for example a panel that's
focused on T cells separate panel
focused on B cells separate panel focus
on myeloid markers in addition site off
is an important aspect of the analysis
if rheumatoid arthritis synovium so much
much like what I've shown you the
network is interested in using sites off
to analyze cell populations in
rheumatoid arthritis tissue obtained at
times through arthropod arthroplasties
which is mostly what I've shown you and
also now with a particular emphasis on
trying to study synovial biopsies of RA
patients that can be obtained oftentimes
earlier in disease or for more focused
patient populations and we use
osteoarthritis tissue as a comparator
and though though I think many many
folks in the network will have different
ways to frame it my way of thinking
about the goals of these studies are to
identify cell populations or phenotypes
that drive pathology and rheumatoid
arthritis and in addition to identify
cellular alterations that define
distinct subsets of rheumatoid arthritis
patients and I think site top is a very
promising way to go about asking these
questions let me conclude by
acknowledging the many people who are
involved in the t cell studies that i
showed you those work is mentored by
Michael Brenner with important
contributions members of his lab the
informatics work is commented by Jean
Marie Chaudhary
with help from graduate students in his
lab Camille slowikowski in China Fonseca
the arthroplasty tissue analyses are
done in collaboration with the Hospital
for Special Surgery and the microscopy
work is done in collaboration with the
University of Birmingham done by
Jennifer Marshall and working with Chris
Buckley and Andrew filer and I'm
indebted to a number of contributors at
Brigham and Women's Hospital for helping
to support this translational immunology
program my funding sports listed at the
bottom and I also want to recognize the
participants on the rheumatoid arthritis
aside in the accelerating medicines
partnership for making some of these
studies possible contributing samples
expertise in the analysis thank you very
much thank you dr. Poulin and dr. ralph
for your informative presentations it's
time for Q&A if you have a question you
like ask doc coolant and/or dr. Rao
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is for dr. Poole in what other
probes besides metal labeled antibodies
can be used in math cytometry analysis
thanks Judy we have several different
reagents that are not antibody based we
have two nucleic acid intercalators
a1 iridium and one radium label that
allow for cell identification we also
have iota deoxy uridine to look at fa
cells if you're doing social studies we
utilize cisplatin as a live dead
discriminator and we also have barcoding
reagents that allow you to multiplex up
to 20 samples and process and run as a
single sample leading to better data
consistency the next one is for dr. Rao
can you comment on if and how enzymatic
digestion impact markers sorry can you
comment on if and how enzymatic to Jess
impacts marker expression yeah this is a
good question so this is something that
we have to pay attention to when we're
dissociating examples that is the
enzymatic digestion cleaving off markers
of interest and it can be particularly
problematic so we spent a fair amount of
time trying to optimize digestion
conditions to not lose critical markers
so cd4 tends to be one that's
particularly susceptible to cleavage for
so take some fiddling and we had
optimized this to try and reduce the
digestion times and lower the digestion
enzyme concentration to not lose markers
of interest for ones that were
particularly important than we would
validate that we hadn't cleaved them off
so for example here we sorted pd-1 hi-c
x zero five negative cells and p1 high
60s by positive cells sorted them and
then rt-pcr to show that the CX c r v
transcript is only in the cells with a
positive surface marker not not cells
alack the marker digestion time
questions can help you to see if you're
losing marker is slowly through the
course of the dissociation but it is but
it is an issue that one has to pay
attention to dr. al how do you prepare
cells from synovial fluid for flow or
mass spectrometry for example do you fly
call or clean it up in some other way
sure so there's a there's a couple ways
to do it for these studies we have I
called them so we put them over a
density central negation to try and
eliminate the granulocytes in synovial
fluid from inflammatory arthritis
patients the vast majority of the cells
are neutrophils and so to analyze the
other modern nuclear cell populations
it's helpful to to remove the
neutrophils first so we did we fight
call them and process them in more or
less the same way that we treated the
blood samples so in both cases we would
fly call them cryopreserved them on our
nuclear cells and then stall them out
and analyze them in batches
it doesn't have to be done that way if
you're interested in the neutrophils you
can you can certainly analyze the total
population but this is how we did it dr.
Ralph how much synovium and cell per
sample are normally obtained from a
procedure so this this depends for if
we're talking about synovial so let me
answer the simple question Ferris and
maybe not what you're asking it's a
novio fluid and it's the number of
modern nuclear cells is reserved for
inflammatory fluids are roughly
proportional to blood so you know you
can estimate somewhere between you know
half a million then a million cells per
mil per synovial tissue it it depends
how you're getting the tissue so from
arthroplasties the joint replacements
you get a fair amount of tissue in there
you can end up with you know millions of
synovial cells in total and if it's a
infiltrated sample you end up with more
cells if it's a relatively bland sample
you end up with fewer for the efforts in
particular in the amp debt were where
there's a pursuit of synovial biopsies
there the amount of tissue that's
collected is much smaller and it depends
on the details of how you're doing the
biopsy and what's the method used to
acquire the tissue but you know it's
it's more in the range of a few hundred
thousand cells to you know up to a
million cells or two for this next one
dr. pooling could you take it first and
then dr. Rao could you comment as well I
have heard about imaging mass cytometry
would this be possible to use on
synovial tissue yes absolutely
early access users of the new imaging
Malphite ometer have not specifically
looked at synovium but they've used a
wide array of tissues both
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded as well
as fresh frozen and some have even
looked at self spread so there's no
reason that synovial tissue could not
also
process and analyze by imaging that
cytometry yeah I agree with that I think
it would be really that would be neat to
do okay next the step one is for dr. Rao
based on your experience how much
expression correlation of surface marker
in immune cells between RNA and protein
data are you observing I guess the in
general at the bulk I mean at the bulk
level if you're comparing an RNA
expression that the bulk level between
sorted populations and the surface
markers on their selves yeah those
correlations seem community to be pretty
good I think maybe the question is more
point that the correlation between
single cell mass cytometry and single
cell RNA sequencing you know
transcriptomics in that case you know I
think it's it's an evolving field and in
a not necessarily question that I have
an answer to but one that's of interest
you know and I just mentioned that the
ability to well I think it well we'll
see how that evolves but at least at the
bulk level here for the specific
targeted proteins we've looked at the
correlations have been quite good
dr. RAL will you also be doing fossil
flow on the rheumatoid arthritis
synovial tissue sample samples and if so
what do you think are some of the key
signaling components to include so
fossil is not not part of you know
phospho signaling analyses are not part
of them i you know that our top
priorities although i think they're
interesting studies to do the I think
the pathways that come to mind in terms
of responses to inflammatory signals and
the joints are you know key ones of
interest and I'm interested to see what
people will find there in dr. Aldus next
one is 32 did you find more activated
b-cells or plasma blasts and patients
with high PD one
see XE XE r5 only half of the rheumatoid
arthritis patients had high PD 1 and CXC
are 5 cells any correlation of this
population with clinical outcome right
good good question so it's a good point
done you know there's a there's a range
of frequencies of peripheral helper
cells in the circulation of RA patients
and what explains that range is is the
question of interest so to stomach there
is there's some association with disease
activity so so they showed you the
patients with higher disease activity
tend to have higher frequencies although
it's not a perfect correlation it is it
is the case also that you know roughly
speaking you tend to see more plasma
blasts in patients that have high
peripheral helper cell frequencies but
but but not a not a great correlation as
we look in relatively small numbers of
patients we're interested in in
additional potential implications of the
an expanded population of peripheral
helper cells that is does it help you
predict the response of particular
therapies does it help you predict
particular manifestations of rheumatoid
arthritis and that's some of the ongoing
work that we're doing okay for dr. Rao
can you comment on other disease types
where this pd-1 hi-c x CR v cd4
population might be found to be expanded
oh yeah we would love to know so this is
that we're interested to see in other
autoimmune inflammatory diseases is
there an expansion of this population of
cells I will be interested to hear what
people see in their own data sets where
I'm sure there are data sets that have
been generated in multiple diseases that
probably have you know the markers in
them to try and ask this question okay
this next one is for you dr. al one
major limitation of cytotoxic seems to
be that at least 50% of labeled cells
are not detected using site off where
Ross would flow cytometry is only about
10
how is this being addressed and there's
a little more to but maybe stamps for
that first so I agree that the losses in
processing are higher with sites often
with flow cytometry and it's done it's
it's one of the reasons actually when we
have very small sample inputs we tend to
prefer running them by flow cytometry
because you can get more of the cells
through to the site ometer you know it's
balanced against the advantages of site
off where you can measure many more
parameters in the same sample
I wonder if Michelle can speak to some
of the technical parts of it but but I
agree that it's it's one of the
considerations when trying to decide
between flow cytometry and mascot
chemistry before Michelle speaks da
Corral would you just want to ask this
last part to it how do we design
experiments to improve the number of
cells that we obtain data from yeah so
one of the things that we found was
particularly important was to make sure
that the cells are well fixed to really
fixed in a in a robust way because you
know the last step is going to put those
cells into distilled water so if they're
not really fixed robustly the lights at
that point and you can lose a fair
number of cells we've tried to to
improve the ways that we're pelleting
the cell to get them down at the bottom
of the tubes and not lose them in the
washes these are some of those steps
that we found those are the spots that
we were losing cells substantial number
of cells along the way dr pawan um so i
would one I would agree with what dr.
Rao said the fixation step is critical
to have better recovery of yourself
throughout the processing it's also very
important that not only should the
fixation step be robust but it's very
important to use freshly diluted
formaldehyde formaldehyde as is exposed
to air will oxidize first to formic acid
and then back to para formaldehyde and
that really impacts its ability to
do an effective fixation of the cells so
always using fresh formaldehyde is
important just due to the way that cells
are focused on the front end of the
instrument into the plasma does incur
some loss this is reduced on our Helios
math site ometer in some cases people
will get actually a 60 to 70 percent
recovery but there is some cell loss
although it is random and not a cell
population specific but that does
require an input of more cells upfront
if you need to get a certain amount of
events out in the data file okay dr.
Ralph could we use these technologies
for Paris and fixed formalin biopsy FFPE
samples I don't think so and for these
for the cellular analysis here you need
intact cells that you can get out into a
single cell suspension I don't I don't
think it's possible from FFPE but that's
that's my understanding of it this next
one is for you - can you follow your CC
r q+ cells migration in vivo and do
these cells have potential to go through
malignant transition as a result of
chronic inflammation so the second part
I have no idea the first part I think
following the cells is a it's an
interesting question it's something
that's probably more easily addressed in
in mouse models than in human human
studies we can't do in-vitro migration
assays and I think they behave as you
would expect but following the cells in
vivo is is can probably most easily
addressed in the mouse model okay we'll
pause for just a quick second here we
are almost out of time you know as we
are almost out of time um I I would just
like to thank dr. Pugh and and dr. Ralph
for their presentations and ask if you
have any final comments
well thanks thanks to the audience for
for being here and thanks for the
opportunity to present this work you
know I think we're optimistic about this
technology and the ability to use this
technology in in combination with others
in a sort of synergistic way to learn
more about the particular the immune
cell populations that infiltrate tissues
and inflammatory diseases thank you very
much okay thank you and dr. pooling we
have another question for you here
before you have closing comments from
once we've opened a new vial of
formaldehyde how long do you suggest we
use it before opening a new one
usually what we recommend is if you have
a an ampule of formaldehyde that you've
opened that once it's opened you then
store it in a 15 ml conical tube wrapped
in foil to protect it from the light and
store that for degree and then use that
within a week okay and on another end
line oh no go ahead do to discern no no
no please please please finish because
we have another one from dr. Rao so
please finish no that that was actually
I was done oh okay um dr. RAL what
controls should you use inside off um so
I think the question is probably getting
a technical controls and trying to
anticipate where the questions coming
from I think so
for one there's this difficulty about
using ISO type controls insights off
just because there's so many antibodies
and I don't necessarily think I have the
right approach here but I can tell you
what we do which is that when we put
together panels so for one we try to use
antibody clones that are that are
established to have a good performance
by flow cytometry for the panels once we
set up a panel and staying in stay in a
cell population
we are looking for whether the antibody
standing follow the expected pattern for
the for the stains but we know they
should look like that is that cd4 signal
should be on the cd3 pause itself the
cd8 signal should be separate from the
cd4 signal and sort of following the
signals down then for markers of
particular interest will we'll use some
of the same tricks that I think we're
familiar with from flow cytometry which
is either to lead out what antibody and
make sure that the signal goes away to
use an iso type control for the stains
that are dim or are particularly
important um and and i think that then
there then there are experimental
controls of you know test controls
versus versus no stimulation controls I
think those but will follow the same
rules and sites off as in other
experimental setups right doctor pullin
do you have final thoughts you'd like to
share I don't have any in particular but
I did just want to say thank you to dr.
Rapp and I was very happy to be part of
this webinar his work is very
interesting and I'm very excited to see
more coming out of his research great
thank you both once again and I would
also like to thank our sponsor fluid I'm
for making today's educational webcast
possible this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CC button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 2017
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that is all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye